النجمه الكولومبيه شاكيرا ولاعب كره القدم
الاسبانيه جرار يعودان يتصدر الاخبار بعد
الفتره الماضيه التي كانت حافله بتطورات
المشهد بين الثنائي الشهير والذين فصل بعد
علاقه دامت 12 عاما ونجم عنها انجاب طفلين
من وقت الانفصال وكشف العلاقه التي تجمع
بين بيكي وحبيبته الجديده وحرب التصريحات
والرسائل المباشره والمبطنه لم تنتهي
والتي زادت حدتها بعد اطلاق شاكيرا
لاغنيتها الشهيره التي سخرت فيها
وحبيبته الجديده ومن بعدها خرج بكيل يرد
بسخريه اكبر وبصوره له لاول مره مع حبيبته
الجديد ان شاكيرا خلال حفل تكريم لها في
احتفاليه
مكان اقامه شاكيرا الجديد مع اطفالها قامت
بتوجيه رساله مبطنه
وقالت انها اكتشفت ان كل امراه هي اقوى
مما تعتقد وياتي وقت في حياه كل امراه لا
تعتمد فيه على شخص ما لتحبه وستقبل نفسها
كما هي ختمت حديثها بكلمات عن الاخلاص
نشاهد مع المقاله شاكيرا
[تصفيق]